hours after some of the continent's
richest clubs threatened to split
european football
in two the sports governing body in
europe uefa hit back
hard saying it will expel the club's
players from future european
championships and world cups i cannot
stress
more strongly at this moment uefa and
the footballing world stand
united against the disgraceful
self-serving proposal we have seen in
the last 24 hours
from a select few clubs in europe that
are fueled purely by greed above all
else
on sunday night 12 of the continent's
richest clubs revealed plans to form a
european
super league rivaling uefa's prestigious
champions league
barcelona real madrid and atletico have
agreed to join in spain
in italy both ac and inter milan have
signed up alongside juventus
and six clubs from england's premier
league also want to join
manchester united city liverpool chelsea
arsenal and tottenham the managers of
the teams have been dodging
awkward questions let's be honest i'm an
employee of this club and i trust this
club
and my job is very clear so i'm maybe
not the right person to ask
i'm just a manager and i'm prepared to
coach my players under any circumstances
the plans even prompted this
intervention from the british prime
minister we're going to look at
everything that
we can do with the football authorities
to
to make sure that this doesn't go ahead
in the way that it's
currently being proposed so far no teams
from france or germany including the
current european champions bayern munich
plan to join the new league
but three more clubs are expected to
sign up
all set to pocket more than 400 million
dollars when they do
in a project funded by u.s banking giant
jp morgan
seriously in the midst of a pandemic an
economic crisis
football clubs at national league level
going bust nearly
furloughing players clubs on the edge in
league one and two and these
are having zoom calls about breaking
away and basically creating more greed
joke the super league clubs want to
start as soon as possible
but the premier league la liga and syria
are have all joined uefa in condemning
the move
so too have many fans competing clubs
face being booted out of their domestic
leagues
several television broadcasters are also
refusing to abandon uefa
and national leagues to join the new
project
but if it does go ahead football's
single sporting pyramid
from the lowest grassroots teams all the
way to the top
may never be the same again neve barker
al jazeera